« Écoute.
Écoute ce que dit le scarabée. »
Je passais des heures et des heures à écouter le petit scarabée
rouler une énorme boule de bouse
et en même temps,
j'entendais plein de bruits autour.
En tendant l'oreille, j'entendais des familles bavarder,
des rires,
le hurlement du vent,
et même les stridulations des grillons.
Tous ces sons s'enchevêtraient,
et j'entendais le rythme qui les animait.
Et je frappais un plat avec une cuillère et ma poitrine avec mes petites mains
en essayant de recréer ce que j'entendais.
J'ai continué à frapper sur ces mêmes assiettes,
maracas, tambours, poêles et tant d'autres choses
pour devenir batteuse et percussionniste
professionnelle.
(Applaudissements)
En grandissant, inconsciemment,
j'ai ressenti le besoin irrépressible de cacher mon nouveau passe-temps.
Même sans en parler,
je savais que ce que je faisais était mal.
Pendant la plupart des cérémonies,
je remarquais qu'on ne voyait ni les femmes ni les petites filles,
et quand elles étaient là,
je remarquais qu'elles portaient leurs tenues de danse
et qu'elles se déhanchaient,
en chantant, frappant des mains, ululant
tandis que les hommes s'occupaient des rythmes.
Quelques années plus tard, j'ai compris
le poids de la tradition et de la culture
et les choses qui étaient taboues
ou non.
Dans la plupart des cultures africaines,
on interdit aux femmes de jouer du tambour ou des percussions
depuis longtemps.
Je pense que ce tabou vient de la croyance traditionnelle
selon laquelle la femme est un être inférieur.
J'ai grandi en entendant dire que la place des femmes était dans la cuisine
ou dans l'autre pièce.
Hum-um ?
(Rires)
On a conditionné les femmes, on les a trompées depuis si longtemps
que maintenant nous avons commencé à y croire.
En y ajoutant l'absence d'intérêt concernant l'éducation féminine,
cela a énormément contribué
à graver cette place dans nos esprits.
Le son du tambour suscite l'émotion et le mouvement.
Le tambour est tout simplement un instrument très sensuel.
A un festival, un homme m'a demandé
comment j'osais mettre un tambour entre mes jambes.
On me considère comme une fille facile, obscène parce je joue.
On me demande constamment
pourquoi j'ai choisi de jouer du tambour
plutôt que de faire du journalisme,
que j'ai étudié pour mon diplôme,
qui est défini comme « plus convenable ».
Jouer des percussions affaiblit une femme,
la rend moins féminine,
moins désirable,
et tout cela la rabaisse à un niveau social inférieur.
Les percussions représentent un héritage africain fort,
et leur importance est visible
dans les nombreux aspects des traditions africaines.
Beaucoup de communautés incluent les percussions dans leur quotidien,
le font même encore actuellement,
pendant les naissances, les cérémonies d'initiation,
les cérémonies d'accueil,
les mariages et même les enterrements.
Cependant, ces mêmes percussions
sont en train de disparaître rapidement de la scène musicale,
et le style traditionnel perd sa popularité
très rapidement parmi la population.
Poussée par le besoin de protéger cette culture,
j'enseigne l'importance et la portée des percussions
à des jeunes garçons, des femmes et des jeunes filles.
Par mon expérience de professeur de percussions,
j'ai réalisé que vraiment beaucoup de femmes
veulent jouer du tambour,
mais en même temps,
en ont peur.
Certaines craignent la manière dont la société va les voir.
D'autres craignent la douleur physique ressentie quand on joue.
Et oui, ce n'est pas si facile.
Certaines ont peur car leur époux n'approuve pas,
et souvent, d'autres craignent la responsabilité
d'être porteur d'une culture.
Je crois, je pense, que toutes ces peurs
sont gravées dans la prudence collective féminine
car quand on entend parler des atrocités qu'ont subies les femmes,
particulièrement sur notre continent,
cela nous rappelle constamment
que s'écarter un peu de la place qui nous a été attribuée
peut avoir des conséquences graves.
Donc, j'utilise mon tambour pour raconter mon histoire et celles de mon peuple.
Mes racines ont façonné mon être et ma culture m'accompagne toujours.
Les femmes peuvent aussi être gardiennes d'une culture.
Nous sommes nées pour apporter la vie,
pour la nourrir.
Sans aucun doute, nous pouvons très bien protéger nos traditions.
Mon tambour et moi,
nous sommes là pour longtemps.
(Applaudissements)
Nous sommes là pour longtemps.
Si les femmes ont dirigé des pays,
sont allées dans l'espace,
ont gagné des Grammys,
alors ces mêmes femmes peuvent jouer des percussions
et en jouer - sur un classement à cinq étoiles ?
Non, un classement à un million d'étoiles.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
(Carillon)
(Son métallique)
(Cliquetis)
(Percussions)
(Applaudissements)